Hallo, guten Tag. Ich bin hier Mehmet Kapaghan. Ich bin hier auf dieser Station als Tanzarzt tätig.
Und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen. Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen oder eine Frage haben, können Sie gerne mir Bescheid sagen.
Ja, gerne.
Bevor wir über Ihre aktuelle Bescheid sprechen, möchte ich ein paar allgemeine Fragen ganz schnell an Sie stellen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, bin ich.
Danke schön. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße, wie heiße ich denn? Wilhelm Meyer.
Wilhelm Meyer.
Genau. Herr Meyer, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 76 Jahre alt.
Wie bitte?
76 Jahre alt.
Ja, 76 Jahre alt. Und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin geboren am 15. April 1946.
Ja.
46 oder 46?
56 oder 40, 40, ich glaube, ja.
46, ja.
Wie schwer sind Sie, Herr Meyer?
Ich bin 80 Kilo schwer.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
75.
Danke schön.
Herr Meyer, was für eine Schwerte haben Sie?
Also, ich verliess nicht, was mit mir los ist.
Meine Frau sagt, ich bin seit zwei, drei Tagen neben der Spur.
Soll heißen, ja, nicht mal so merkwürdige Dinge.
Wenn sie mich daran fragt, sage ich, weiß ich nicht, habe ich nicht gemerkt.
Also, was haben Sie bemerkt?
Seit drei Tagen.
Ich habe nichts gemerkt.
Meine Frau sagt, ich rede manchmal unsinniges Zeug.
Und ich mache manchmal Dinge, was keinen Sinn ergibt.
Okay.
Und sind Ihnen Benomenheit bekannt?
Bein in der letzten Zeit?
Mir nicht, aber meiner Frau, ja.
Okay.
Aber diese Schwerte sind bei Ihnen, ja?
Also, ich habe keine Beschwerden.
Ich merke nichts davon.
Meine Frau sagt, ich bin nicht mehr der Alte.
Ich mache manchmal Dinge, wo sie sagt, das passt nicht.
Das kenne ich nicht.
Okay.
Alles klar.
Und haben Sie andere Beschwerden?
Zum Beispiel Korschmersen oder andere Taupheizgefühle
in Ihren Körperteilen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Keine Kopfschmerzen und auch keine Empfindungsstörung.
Okay.
Sehen Sie etwas, das Ihre Frau auch nicht gut sehen kann?
Zum Beispiel, wenn Sie etwas sehen würden,
dann Ihre Frau sagte, dass jemand nicht dort ist.
Oder habe ich mitgekürzt?
Ja, keine Halluzinationen.
Das nicht.
Keine Halluzinationen.
Aber ich würde manchmal Dinge machen,
irgendwelche Gegenstände von irgendetwas wegnehmen,
wieder hintun.
Oder manchmal irgendwelche komischen Bemerkungen machen,
wo sie dann sagt, das ist doch jetzt gar nicht der richtige Zeitpunkt.
Nach dem Motto zum Beispiel, ich gebe mal ein Beispiel.
Ich sage dann, meine Frau,
du hast doch heute Geburtstag, dann sagt sie,
mein Geburtstag ist doch vor drei Monaten gewesen.
Okay, aber ist die Wahrheit,
ist Ihr Aussage, ist Wahrheit?
Nein, meine Aussage ist nicht.
Aber meine Frau sagt, das ist richtig so.
Meine Frau sagt das, was ich sage, stimmt nicht.
Sie hat keinen Geburtstag.
Ihr Geburtstag war vor drei Monaten gewesen.
Dann gehe ich manchmal im Wohnzimmer herum,
nehme eine Blume, tue sie auf den Boden, dann sagt sie,
warum habt ihr das gemacht?
Ich soll das doch runtermachen, sagt sie, wieso denn?
Okay, okay, haben Sie falsche Wahrnehmung?
Was mag ich denn?
Wahrnehmung, Wahrnehmung.
Mit falschen Wahrnehmung, oder?
Wahrnehmungstörung, meine ich.
Ja, Wahrnehmungstörung, leiden Sie darunter?
Nein, nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Okay, leiden Sie unter Sitter?
Manchmal in Ihren Körperteilen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay, seit drei Tagen haben Sie diese Beschwerden eigentlich?
Sie habe gesagt, dass Sie keine Beschwerden haben,
nur Ihre Frau sagt das, ja?
Ja, ich bin auch jetzt gekommen,
weil meine Frau gesagt hat, das geht so nicht weiter,
sondern ich habe sie nicht mehr gesehen.
Okay, okay.
Ist Ihnen noch etwas aufgefallen?
Eigentlich nicht.
Okay.
Wussten Sie zurzeit?
Wussten, ja, schon immer, ja.
Morgen, ich rauche, von daher habe ich immer wussten,
ist jetzt nicht besonders.
Leiden Sie unter Atemnot?
Ja, wenn ich so Treppen steige oder so laufe Belastungsabhängig, ja,
bisschen.
Leiden Sie unter Herzrasen oder Herzstoppen?
Nein, nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Okay, haben Sie Fieber bemerkt?
Fieber, Fieber habe ich nicht gehabt.
Leiden Sie unter Stürfrost oder Nachtschweiß?
Nachtschweiß, ja.
Ich weiß nicht, was Sie mit Nachtschweiß meinen.
Schweißausbruch in der Nacht?
In der Nacht, ja.
Hin und wieder bin ich dann Nacht verschwitzt.
Ja, das und Akkonto,
musste ich auch mal die Wäsche wechseln, das ist richtig.
Okay, Nachtschweiß, leiden Sie darunter.
Seit wann?
Seit einem halben Jahr.
Leiden Sie unter Durchfall oder Verstopfen?
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Okay, leiden Sie oder haben Sie Schmerzen beim Wasser lassen
oder mit dem Sturrgern?
Nein, das habe ich auch nicht.
Okay, noch etwas ist Ihnen aufgefallen,
bei Ihrem Bauch oder zum Beispiel Belähungen oder Saueraustossen?
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Okay, Taubheizgefühl oder Benomenheit
oder sind Ihnen vor Augen schwarz?
Nein, das habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Haben Sie erwrochen oder ist Ihnen übel?
Das auch nicht, nein.
Ich möchte wieder Ihre aktuelle Beschwerde etwas fragen.
Seit drei Tagen haben Sie diese Beschwerden.
Ich möchte wieder sicher sein, dass ich Sie richtig verstanden bin.
Ich habe sie verstanden.
Seit drei Tagen haben Sie gesagt,
dass Ihre Frau sagt, Sie haben etwas falsche Dinge gesagt.
Ja, ja.
Wie man so etwas bezeichnet, man sagt, ich sei verwirrt.
Wie?
Meine Frau sagt, ich sei verwirrt.
Genau, ja. Aber Sie glauben nichts.
Ich weiß nicht, ich kann sein, ich glaube meiner Frau,
wenn sie so etwas sagt, dann wird da schon etwas sein,
sonst wäre ich nicht ins Krankenhaus gekommen.
Deswegen bin ich da, damit das kontrolliert wird.
Das passt nicht, das tut mir leid.
Wenn sie sagt, ich mache Dinge, wo sie traurig ist,
wo ich sie damit verletze, das will ich nicht.
Hatten Sie früher eine Beschwerde?
Nein, das kenne ich nicht.
Meine Frau sagt, es gab es auch früher nicht.
Seit drei Tagen sind diese Beschwerden gelöst?
Oder langsam im Laufe der Zeit verschlimmert?
Nein, in den drei Tagen, wie Sie gekommen sind.
Ich bin seit drei Tagen wohl hin und wieder immer wieder mal verwirrt.
Okay.
Waren Sie beim anderen Arzt wegen dieser Beschwerden?
Nein, ich kenne mich.
Okay.
Ich möchte eine kurze Zusammenfassung für Ihre Beschwerden.
Hab ich gemalt?
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen über Ihre Beschwerden?
Aktuelle Beschwerden?
Nein, ich möchte nur, dass das abgeklärt wird,
dass Sie meine Frau sich keine Sorgen machen.
Okay, danke schön.
Ich möchte jetzt nach Ihrer Vorgeschichte, Vorerkrankungen etwas fragen.
Leiden Sie an einer wichtigen Vorerkrankung,
von den ich wissen sollte?
Mit Bluthochdruck habe ich zu tun.
Seit wann?
Nur da, dass das vielleicht seit 20 Jahren der Fall ist.
20 Jahre?
Ja, ich nehme sogar zwei Medikamente ein.
Mein Hausarzt hat mir 5 Milligramm bisoprolol gegeben.
Ganz am Anfang.
Und jetzt nehme ich noch Atakanth dazu ein.
Wer ist es?
Bisoprolol, 5 Milligramm.
Und Atakanth.
Atakanth, okay.
Wie viele Milligramm?
15 Milligramm.
16 Milligramm, okay.
Und wie viel Tag, wie viel Mal am Tag?
Von der Bisoprolol nehme ich morgens eine ein.
Und von der Atakanth nehme ich eine morgens eine Abend ein.
Okay, danke schön.
Und noch andere Vorerkrankungen?
Ja, ich habe noch eine.
Ich habe noch eine.
Und noch andere Vorerkrankungen?
Habt ihr sie?
Ja, mir ist der Blinddarm entfernt worden.
Schon als Kind.
Und die Granblase wurde mir vor 10 Jahren entfernt.
Granblase entfernt, ja.
Wann war das?
Die Granblase vor 10 Jahren.
Vor 10 Jahren.
Okay, danke schön.
Ansonsten keine weitere Operationen, ja?
Nein, sonst keine weiteren Operationen.
Sind Sie gegen etwas allergisch?
Nein, wir sind nicht bekannt.
Okay, Unverträglichkeiten sind bei Ihnen bekannt?
Nein, nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie rauchen.
Seit wann rauchen Sie?
Oh, bestimmt schon über 50 Jahre.
Über 50 Jahre.
Wie viel mal am Tag?
Wie viel Zigaretten am Tag?
Also das hat sich immer wieder mal geändert.
Mal eine Packung, mal anderthalb.
Jetzt rauche ich weniger als eine Packung.
Ich habe eine durchschnittliche An- dath- Packung.
Okay, eine An- dath- Packung, ja.
Trink ist sie Alkohol?
Nein, gar nicht.
Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich,
das ist eine medizinische Frage.
Ich muss Sie fragen, dass Sie Drogen nehmen.
Drogen? Nein.
Damit darf ich nicht sagen.
Nein, mit 76 Jahren muss ich keinen Sport mitmachen.
Genau, ja.
Wie ist die Impfstatus?
Sind Sie regelmäßig geimpft?
Was machen Sie damit?
Gegen Covid?
Genau, gegen Covid und gegen andere Kinderheißimpfungen?
Gegen Kinderimpfungen, ja.
Wissen Sie, mit 76 Jahren, das war ja kurz nach dem Krieg.
Ja, das weiß ich gar nicht mehr.
Aber gegen Covid bin ich geimpft.
Gibt es auch für die geriatrischen,
für die älteren Menschen auch Impfungen?
Zum Beispiel Peno Mo Co, oder andere Impfungen.
Haben Sie auch erhaltet?
Ja, mein Haus hat sich gemäßt.
Ich weiß nicht, was er alles geimpft hat,
aber er sagt, er will noch Grippe impfen,
und das, was er sagt, mache ich dann auch.
Sind Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland gewesen?
Nein, ich bin nicht im Ausland, schon seit Jahren nicht.
Ich möchte jetzt nach Ihrer Familienanomase etwas fragen.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstatus?
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet, aber ich bin momentan verwitmet.
Ich habe meine Frau vor fünf Jahren verloren.
Ich kann ja nicht sein, aber meine Frau ist ja da.
Meine Frau hat ja beobachtet,
dass es mir nicht gut geht, wie ich sie wird.
Genau, ja, ich habe es verstanden.
Ihre Frau ist gestorben?
Die ist nicht gestorben, nein, die ist nicht gestorben.
Okay, alles klar, ich habe gedacht,
vielleicht, dass Sie mit Ihrer Frau
in einer Zeitung, in einer Zeitung,
mit Ihrer Frau gesprochen haben,
noch mit Ihrer Frau gestorben haben?
Nein, nein, nein, die ist da und habe ihr verheiratet.
Sie haben auch...
ich lebe mit meiner Frau zusammen, ja.
Wir haben auch zwei Kinder, die sind schon erwachsen,
die sind auch zu Hause,
Wir haben geregelte Berufe und damit haben wir keine Probleme.
Kinder, Sohn oder Tochter?
Zwei Söhne.
Haben Sie zwei Kinder?
Ja.
Beide sind gesund.
Sie habe gesagt?
Die sind beide gesund.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe noch eine Schwester.
Die ist älter als ich.
Die ist über 80.
Die hat ein paar Krankheiten.
Aber es geht hier sonst so weit gut.
Welche Krankheiten hat sie?
Die hat ein Diabetes, hat einen Schlaganzahl gehabt.
Und sie lebt im Pflegeheim.
Okay.
Was haben Sie als beruflich gemacht?
Ich vermute, dass Sie in Wänden sind.
Ich war Elektrotechniker.
Wie bitte?
Elektrotechniker.
Ihr könnt es recht erinnern.
Elektro wie elektrisch.
Elektrotechniker.
Okay.
War Ihr Arbeit gut?
Und waren Sie damit zufrieden?
Ja, nach dem Krieg.
Irgendwann habe ich das gelernt.
Und bis zum Rentenalter habe ich durchgearbeitet.
Ich möchte etwas über Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden noch fragen.
Können Sie die frühe Geschichte gut erinnern?
Oder können Sie gestrige Geschichte gut erinnern?
Zum Beispiel, was gestern passiert ist?
Ich kann mich immer noch.
Sie meinen, ob ich dement bin.
Ich kann mich noch an alles gut erinnern.
Wie gesagt, es ist nur so,
dass bestimmte seit drei Tagen passieren,
dass ich nicht zuordnen kann.
Ich bin ein bisschen verwirrt, sagt meine Frau.
Ich war vor vier Tagen oder einer Woche.
Darum kann ich mich noch sehr gut erinnern.
Okay.
Danke schön.
Momentan, leider so unter Stress.
Soll man als Rentner zu Stress haben?
Nein, kein Stress.
Danke schön.
Meine Seite habe ich alle wichtige Fragen an Sie gestellt.
Können Sie gerne mir fragen?
Möchten Sie etwas hinschüpfigen?
Vielleicht sollte ich noch erwähnen.
In den letzten sechs Monaten habe ich ungefähr 10 kg
an Gewicht verloren.
Okay.
Genau.
In den letzten fünf Monaten?
Ja, in den letzten sechs Monaten.
Okay.
Haben Sie Nervknoten in den Hasperais
oder in den Direktörverteilen bemerkt?
Was sind Nervknoten?
Nervknoten oder Vergrößerung?
Nein, ich habe nicht geschwörenden.
Nein, okay.
Ich habe nicht geschwörenden.
Wie ist der Appetit?
Mein Appetit, meiner Meinung nach immer noch gut.
Ich habe immer noch alles auf dem Tisch gekauft.
Okay.
Danke schön.
Bitte schön.
Heute ist das erste Mal für mich.
Deshalb bin ich auch ein bisschen aufgeregt.
Ich hoffe, dass ich Sie richtig verstanden habe.
Ja, das wird schon richtig sein.
Ich habe etwas Speziellem ausgesucht.
Mal gucken, ob Sie dem auf die Spur kommen werden.
Es ist nicht immer alles sehr einfach.
Vor allem nicht im Krankenhaus.
Aber bestimmte Dinge sind wichtige Hinweise dafür.
Wenn Sie die Hinweise verstehen,
wissen Sie auch, was Sie zu tun haben.
Dann gucken wir mal gleich.
Gibt es noch Fragen von anderen?
Können Sie gut sehen?
Nein, ich muss nicht gut sehen.
Ja, so wie im Alter.
Ich brauche schon eine Brille, aber das ist nichts Neues.
Verzehren Sie in der letzten Seite ungewöhnliche Nahrungsmittel
oder Konserven?
Nein, ich bin nicht gut.
Können Sie alle Bekannteadressen gut finden?
Nein, damit habe ich kein Problem.
Mein Problem ist, dass meine Frau seit drei Tagen beobachtet hat,
dass sie sich ein bisschen verwirrt haben.
Aber sonst habe ich keine Probleme.
Ich bin ja noch Auto gefahren vor einer Woche.
Jetzt sind Sie auch, jetzt sind sie zu dringend?
Das nicht.
Herr Meier, ich möchte Ihnen erklären, wie wir weitergehen können.
Ja, vorgehen wollen.
Genau, jetzt würde ich Sie Köpel schuttersuchen.
Dann möchte ich von Ihnen Blut abnehmen wegen dieser Beschwerden
und bestimmte Blutwerte würde ich anschauen.
Mit diesem anemästischen Angaben und Blut,
mit diesem Untersuchungsbefunde, möchte ich mit dem Oberarzt sprechen.
Nach dieser Besprechung werde ich zu Ihnen kommen,
sage ich Ihnen, wie wir vorgehen können.
Und jetzt müssen Sie bleiben für weitere Behandlung
und für weitere Untersuchungen und Behandlung.
Danke.
Und können wir das Arztgespräch auch machen, wenn Sie Zeit haben?
Ja, klar.
Herr Oberarzt, hätten Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ich habe gerade einen neuen Patienten auch genommen,
den ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Herr Wilhelm Meier, den ich gerade aufgenommen habe,
ist 76 Jahre alt, 80 Kilogramm schwer und 1,75 Meter groß.
Herr Wilhelm Meier hat sich heute bei uns
wegen seit drei Tagen ungewöhnliche Verhalten vorgestellt.
Die Geschichte ist so, die Frau von dem Patienten habe gesagt,
dass der Patient eine ungewöhnliche Verhalten erlebt habe,
zum Beispiel manche Dinge gemacht habe und die Dinge in der Tat nicht so.
Der Patient glaubt auch nicht diese Verhalten,
aber wegen der Aussage von seiner Frau kam er zu uns.
Ansonsten leidet er über Nachtschweiß seit sechs Monaten
und eine gewisse Abnahme von zehn Kilogramm von innenwesten sechs Monaten.
Und Atemnot, HBR ein bisschen,
ansonsten HBR keine weitere Symptome.
Die Analyse ist ja angabend, die vegetative Analyse sei unabhängig,
bis auf oben genannte Symptome.
Die Vorgeschichte ergab eine Artilleriepertomie seit 20 Jahren.
Dagegen nehmen der Patient bis auf Rohlor fünf Milligramm einmal pro Tag ein
und attacken 16 Milligramm, zwei Mal morgens und abends am Tag ein.
Bei diesen Patienten sei eine Appendectomy als Kind durchgebrut worden
und eine Kolesistikdomie sei vor zehn Jahren durchgeführt worden.
Allergie und Unrechtlichkeiten wurden verneint.
Und Sport, die Frage nach Sport und Impfstatus und Leise sei unabhängig.
Der Patient hatte keine Stress zurzeit und Parasitasee, Halicinationen
und Demenz oder Amnesie wurden verneint.
Der Patient saugert seit über 50 Jahren, ungefähr ein halb Päckung am Tag,
das heißt 75 Päckungen.
Der Patient sei verheiratet und lebt mit seiner Frau zusammen.
Er hat zwei Kinder, zwei Söhne, die gesund sind.
Er hat eine Schwester, die über 80 Jahre alt war und die lebt noch.
Die Schwester leidet an einer Diabetes Militus, Typ 2 und Apopulix.
Sie lebt momentan in einer Pflege.
Der Patient hat als Elektro-Techniker früher gearbeitet.
Er sei in der Retina.
Die Analystische Angaben der Deutschen Ameristin auf eine Malignite
wegen dieser Nachtschweiß und Gewissabnahme 10 Kilogramm.
Denke ich diese Malignite.
Vielleicht in Hintermörr können wir auch sagen.
Eine Hintermörr.
Und auch möchte ich sagen, die Lernfknoten, auch die Frage nach Lernfknoten
und die Frage auch nach ähnliche Beschwerden in der Vergangenheit,
die aus differenzial Diagnose kommen,
multiple Mioloma, Hiltömer oder...
Ja, ich würde jetzt gar nicht in Richtung Tumorerkrankungen gehen.
Das können Sie auch gar nicht in der Notaufnahme.
Das muss man Schritt für Schritt machen.
Sie müssen keine Differenzialdiagnosen erwähnen.
Aber später wird man schon bestimmte Dinge erwähnen müssen.
Weil der Grund, warum der Patient ins Krankenhaus gekommen ist,
ist nicht, weil er Gewicht verloren hat,
sondern dieser Verwirrtheits-Tumor.
Er ist zeitlich und er ist ürmlich ein bisschen verwirrt.
Das ist der Hauptgrund, weshalb er da ist.
Und dem müssen wir jetzt nachgehen.
Die Frage ist, was machen wir jetzt?
Sie haben Blut abgenommen, Sie haben einen Untersuch.
Haben Sie bei den körperlichen Untersuchungen was Auffälliges bemerkt?
Auffälliges habe ich bei den körperlichen Untersuchungen.
Parastasy habe ich nicht bemerkt, ist unauffällig, ist keine.
Und Kraftlosigkeit habe ich nicht gefragt bei den anderen.
Aber muss ich bei den körperlichen Untersuchungen?
Muss man fragen, aber hat er nicht gehabt?
Er hat keine neurologischen Ausfälle.
Es sieht alles soweit gut aus.
Sie haben jetzt nichts Neurologisches festgestellt.
Aber die Angehörigen, man sagt fremd anamnestisch,
wird über einen Verwirrtheitszustand berichtet.
Man kann auch sagen, wenn man das dem Oberast übergibt,
die Ehefrau berichtet fremd anamnestisch über eine örtliche
und zeitliche Verwirrtheit seit drei Tagen.
Der Patient selber gibt ein Gewichtsverlust seit einem halben Jahr
plus Nachtschweiß an.
Gut, das ist die eigentliche Anamnese, die wir wissen wollen.
Jetzt müssen Sie Schritt zu Schritt arbeiten.
Sie haben den körperlichen Untersuch.
Sie haben nichts Auffälliges gesehen oder gehört.
Jetzt gucken wir uns mal das Labor an.
EKG war unauffällig, darauf wollen wir uns jetzt nicht stürzen.
Und im Labor, Sie haben Blut abgenommen.
Sie haben Serumröhrchen abgenommen.
Blutbild merken wir, der hat so Leukozytten von 11.000, 12.000.
Ein Hb von ungefähr 9 Gramm pro D-Ziliter.
Tombozytten normal, ein MTV von, was weiß ich, 76 AFL.
Und dann sehen wir aber in der Serologie, er hat ein Natrium,
was normal ist, ein Kalium ist normal
und Calcium ist bei 3,8 Millimolpoliter
und Kreatinien ist normal und die LDH ist bei 400.
Und kein CRP.
Was machen wir jetzt da?
Also, was sofort auffallen muss, ist, auf dem Laborzettel gibt es
auch die Normalwerte für Natrium, Kalium, Kalium.
Und Kalium, normalwerte geht ja eigentlich bis 2,6.
Und wenn Sie einen Wert von 3,6, 3,8 haben,
dann haben Sie eine Hyperkalzämie.
Und was man wissen muss, was man wissen muss,
ist, dass Menschen mit einer Hyperkalzämie neurologisch
auffällig werden.
Das macht eine Verwirrtheit, so als wenn jemand ein Apoplexat.
Was man aber nebenbei auf jeden Fall machen muss.
Sie haben also schon einen Hinweis, der hat eine Hyperkalzämie.
Sie können sagen, das klärt schon die neurologische Symptomatik,
aber der Mann hat Gewichtsverlust, der Mann schwitzt nachts,
hat Nachtschweiß.
Also machen Sie von der Notaufnahme aus ein Notfall CT vom Schädel.
Um sicherzustellen, dass er keinen Tumor hat.
Was ja auch das Ganze verursachen kann.
Und Sie machen einen CT und der Radiologe sagt,
das ist alles in Ordnung, der hat keinen Tumor.
Und jetzt muss Ihr nächster Schritt sein,
dieses Kalzium zu senken.
Weil das ist die Ursache für den Verwirrtheitzustand des Patienten.
Wissen Sie, wie man so notfällig Kalium senken kann?
Haben Sie schon mal davon etwas gehört,
eine hyperkalzämische Krise oder Hyperkalzämie, wie man das behandelt?
Hyperkalzämie mit Hyperparatiroidämie.
Hyperparatiroidämie können hoch sein, oder?
Ja, die dehormonischen, gehen erstmal keine Rolle.
Das stimmen wir im Nachhinein.
Aber wie die Behandlung, die Akutbehandlung von Hyperkalzämie.
Kalzium-Blu-Conat?
Nein, drinnen zum Gegenteil.
Der hat zu viel Kalzium.
Sie dürfen ihm keinen Kalzium geben.
Das ist falsch.
Sie müssen etwas geben, was das Kalzium senkt.
Da schreibt jemand Infusionen mit isotonischen Lösungen.
Das hilft nicht.
Sie brauchen irgendetwas rein logisch gesehen,
was aus der Blutbahn Kalzium in die Zellen hineinträgt.
Das Medikament, das so etwas macht, nennt man bisphosphonate.
Bisphosphonate, genau.
Also, gängigsten Mittel in Deutschland,
da gibt es zwei Gruppen, einmal die Zollerdronatgruppe
oder aber die Pamidronatgruppe.
Wenn jemand mit so etwas kommt,
dann müssen sie notfallmäßig bisphosphonate geben.
Die haben unterschiedliche Dosisangaben.
Wenn die Niere in Ordnung ist, geben sie Zollerdronat, 4 mg.
Wenn die Niere nicht so gut ist,
geben sie Pamidronat, richtig mg. oder 90 mg.
Je nachdem mit der gewünschten Laufzeit.
Nur dadurch können sie sein Kalzium senken.
Früher hat man gesagt,
Flüssigkeit geben plus Diuretika, Schleipendiuretika.
Es gibt auch die Empfehlung hier und da,
dass man z.B. Salvotamol-Inhalationen machen soll.
Das soll auch die Kalzimis senken.
Aber Haupttherapie ist bisphosphonate.
Man darf nur nicht erwarten,
dass diese Hyperkalzimie innerhalb von Minuten runtergeht.
Das braucht manchmal mehrere Tage.
Das bedeutet, dieser Mensch, der muss stationär aufgenommen werden.
Den kann man nicht nach Hause lassen.
Der muss da bleiben.
Der braucht täglich Laborkontrollen.
Der braucht sicherlich auch Flüssigkeit.
Die isotonische Flüssigkeit ist jetzt nicht ganz verkehrt.
Aber alleine diese isotonische Flüssigkeit
würde das Kalzium nicht senken.
Sie haben sich jetzt auf das Kalzium draus geschmissen.
Jetzt haben sie gesagt,
wir kriegen bisphosphonate, die Hyperkalzimie,
haben wir gesenkt.
Das erste Schritt ist jetzt,
warum hat er diese Hyperkalzimie?
Die Ursache.
Und jetzt müssen Sie sich auch die Suche machen.
Welche Möglichkeiten gibt es denn der Hyperkalzimie?
Osterkurse?
Man unterscheidet erst mal zwei Gruppen.
Einmal die krimäre Hyperkalzimie
mit einem Hyperparaturidismus.
Aber eine sekundäre Form,
das ist einfach eine paranäoplastische Hyperkalzimie.
Und Sie wollen erst mal gucken,
hat der etwas Primäres,
dann nehmen Sie einfach die Nebenschilddrüsen-Hormone ab.
Paratomonen, oder aber, was weiß ich noch, was dazu gehört.
Sie sehen aber, Paratomonen ist völlig normal.
Normaler.
Ja, aber es hat ich Ihnen auch vorher sagen können,
dass das normal sein wird.
Und ich weiß nicht, warum selbst,
weil der Patient gibt Hinweise für eine maligene Erkrankung.
Dann wird das auch ein paranäoplastische Hyperkalzimie sein.
Aber es gibt auch ein Paratomon
für paranäoplastische Hyperkalzimien.
Wissen Sie, wenn man den bezeichnet,
das ist dieses Kumo-related Paratomon.
Und diese Formen muss man speziell bestimmen.
Und die wird mit Sicherheit hoch sein.
Nicht das normale Paratomon,
sondern das assoziierte tumor-related Paratomon
wird natürlich hoch sein.
Jetzt müssen Sie gucken,
oder wissen Sie vielleicht auswendig,
welche Erkrankungen überwiegend paranäoplastisch
eine Hyperkalzimie auslöben?
Ja, natürlich bei multivierlosen Hyperkalzimien
können wir auch sehen.
Ja, sehr gut.
Das macht aber eine primäre Ursache.
Das macht eine primäre Hyperkalzimie.
Warum? Ohne Paratomon,
weil das Myolom den Knochen zersetzt.
Da wird einfach die Prosikalzium freigetämmt.
Aber viel wichtiger ist,
dass dieses paranäoplastische Phänomen.
Welche Erkrankungen machen paranäoplastische Hyperkalzimien?
Langen Krebs, lungenerkrankungen.
Gut, sehr gut.
Hier weiter.
Langen Karzinom.
Der Mann hat Hinweise dafür gegeben,
dass er möglicherweise einen Langen Karzinom leidet.
Er raucht, hat 75 Päckchen,
er hat noch Schwein,
und er hat Gewichtsverlust.
Also muss ein nächster Schritt sein,
erst mal ein Röntgen von der Lunge.
Genau, er hat ein bisschen Atemnot im Lachel.
Richtig, dann machen Sie erst mal
ein Röntgen von der Lunge.
Und Sie sehen, der hat irgendwo rechts zentral
irgendeine Raumvorhabe.
Dann sagen Sie, da ist der Verdacht,
dass er möglicherweise ein NTL hat.
Eine Neoplasie.
Und im zweiten Schritt machen Sie dann ein CT.
Eine Computertomografie.
Und dann sagt der Radiologe,
ja, rechts zentral sieht man eine
ca. 5-6 cm große Raumforderung
mit rechts-hileeren und mediaschinalen Lümschknoten.
Und das ist hochgradig verdächtig
auf ein Bonchiakarzinom.
Und wenn man jetzt wissen wollte,
welche Sorte von Lungenkarzinomen
überwiegend eine paranäoplastische
Hyperkalzynie machen,
nun da ist es so, dass vermehrt
nicht kleinställige Lungenkarzinome
Hyperkalzynien machen.
Während kleinzällige Lungenkarzinome
eher neurologische Probleme haben.
Zum Beispiel, oder andere endocrinologische.
Ein SEADH oder irgendwelche
hormonelle Störungen, die zu neurologischen
Problemen führen, wodurch dann die
Patienten primär in die Neurologie
aufgenommen werden, das sind meistens
kleinställige Lungenkarzinome.
Aber eine paranäoplastische Hyperkalzynie
ist meistens mit einem nicht
kleinställigen Lungenkarzinom verbunden.
Gut, jetzt haben Sie den CT gemacht.
Was ist denn Ihr nächster Schritt?
Was machen Sie mit dem dann?
Eine Lungenarzt-Konsilantworte?
Nein, hier in Deutschland, ja,
Sie sind der internistische Arzt.
Und Konsole und so weiter macht man da nicht,
sondern Sie müssen selber entscheiden.
Wenn Sie nur ein Konsole antworten,
dass jemand dann die Notwendigkeit
einer Bonchuskopie sieht, dann werden
die Sauer, die sind verärgert und sagen,
Sie können doch selber entscheiden, ob
eine Bonchuskopie braucht oder nicht.
Wenn Sie einen Tumor verdacht haben,
müssen Sie eine Bonchuskopie anmenden.
Wir brauchen eine Oberentnahme.
Wenn Sie natürlich in einem kleinen Haus
arbeiten, wo keine Bonchuskopie
Abteilung gibt, dann müssen Sie diesen
Menschen irgendwo hinverlegen,
wo eine Bonchuskopie gemacht werden kann.
Gut, nehmen wir mal an, bei Ihnen im Haus
werden Bonchuskopien gemacht.
Sie melden zur Bonchuskopie an
und der Lungenarzt oder derjenige,
der die Bonchuskopie gemacht hat,
liebt das Rechtszentral der Hauptbranchus
durch einen Tumor verengt.
Er nimmt da ausreichend Probeentnahmen
und sagt, Histologien,
ein Staging machen.
Und was gehört alles zum Staging
bei Lungenkarcinomen oder
Verdacht auf Lungenkarcinomen?
Was müssen Sie noch machen?
Sie hatten ein CT von der Lunge gemacht.
Jetzt müssen Sie den Staging komplizieren.
Und zwar noch mit einem CT-Abdomen.
Und obwohl Sie ein CT vom Schädel gemacht haben,
müssen Sie trotzdem eine Kernspin-Tomographie machen.
Ja.
Und nur wenn Sie die Kernspin-Tomographie machen,
können Sie nicht sicherheit sagen,
ob jemand Hirnmetastasen hat oder nicht.
Jetzt haben Sie das Staging kompliziert
und die Histologie kommt.
Und die Histologie sagt ein pulmonales
Adenokarsinom.
Und man sieht im CT-Abdomen Lebermetastasen,
aber der Mann hat keine Knochenmetastasen.
Ja?
Und dann haben Sie am Ende Ihre Diagnose fertiggestellt.
Dann sagen Sie, das ist eine paranäoplastische
Hyperkalzämie mit neurologischer
Diagnose-Tomatik.
Bei Erstdiagnose Lungenkarsinom, nicht kleinverlegt,
dystologisch Adenokarsinom.
Aber ein Stadium hier in dem Fall.
Und jetzt behandeln Sie die Hyperkalzämie.
Sie haben Ihnen ja schon Biskuss-Vonate gegeben.
Flüssigkeit.
Und dann kontrollieren Sie jeden Tag, bis sein Kalzium in normalen
Bereiche runtergegangen ist.
Und dann haben Sie die Hygienik, die Sie schon mal
wieder entlassen.
Was die Therapie angeht, weiß ich nicht, ob Sie schon mal mit
Lungenkarsinomen zu tun gehabt haben.
Bei Lungenkarsinomen, vor allem nicht kleinzellig,
macht man heutzutage eine sogenannte
Molekularpathologie.
Die Tumorzellen können viele verschiedene
Mutationen aufweisen.
Und diese Mutationen können auch
verhandelt werden können.
Man spricht vom Englischen her eine Molekulatage der Therapie.
Diese Therapien wirken viel, viel besser
als die Chemotherapie.
Deswegen sagt man zunächst, dass der
Ergebnis dieser molekularen Untersuchungen
abwarten.
Und nur, wenn die alle negativ sind, dann die
Medizin.
Das ist etwas, was der Onkologe behandelt muss.
Sie haben als Assistenzarzt,
der Inneren, ihre Aufgabe erfüllt.
Sie haben eine Paraneo-Plastische Hyperkalzemie
als Ursache für die angegebene Verwirklichkeit
festgestellt.
Und als Ursache haben Sie ein nicht kleinzelliges Lungenkarsinom
festgestellt im Stadion 4,
und jetzt wird der Oberarzt Ihnen sagen,
wir müssen diesen Menschen an einen Onkologen
oder in die Onkologie im Krankenhaus
weiterleiten.
So weit verstanden?
Ja, verstanden, danke schön.
Das ist guter Frage.
So weit, okay, oder gibt es Fragen?
Bei mir keine Frage.
Gibt es jemand überhaupt mal,
mit so einem Problem zu schon gehabt,
auch von den anderen zu hören?
Gibt es jemand so eine Hyperkalzemie,
so eine neurologische Verwirrtheit bei Hyperkalzemie?
Bei mir, oder?
Wir sehen, ob jemand anderes mal so etwas gehört hat.
Okay, in der Bücher,
im Studium habe ich diese Fälle auch
gekannt und kennengelernt.
Paraneuplastische Hyperkalzemie
haben wir viele Fälle gelernt.
Aber ich habe in der Türkei
ein Jahr in der Notaufnahme gearbeitet.
Mein Studium habe ich 2017 abgeschlossen.
Seit zwei Jahren bin ich in Deutschland.
Meine erstliche Erfahrung ist ein Jahr.
Deshalb habe ich nicht bis jetzt
erfahren.
Ja, ist natürlich okay.
Aber wie gesagt, diese neurologische Problematik,
das ist das, was viele Leute überfordert.
Man denkt im ersten Moment, dass es was apoplekt,
oder was ähnlich ist.
Und ein Internist, der so etwas mal gehört hat,
der weiß dann sofort, das hat mit dem Calcium zu tun.
Und nur, wenn die Problematik nach Calciumsenkung nicht besser wird,
dann muss man immer als Internist oder Assistenzarzt
der inneren Abteilung in der Notaufnahme immer denken.
Nun und wieder habe ich mal erlebt,
dass Assistenzärzte Patienten
mit solchen Sachen mal stationell aufgenommen haben.
Und der Patient hat dann zwei Tage auf der Station gelegen,
am Wochenende.
Dann komme ich am Montag, gucke mir die Werte an und sehe,
der hat eine Hyperkalzemie.
Und dann haben wir gesagt, ganz schnell, bis vor der Sonate,
sofort, das ist nur eine notfallmäßige Therapie.
Und innerhalb von ein, zwei, drei, Tagen, vier Tagen
geht dann das Calcium runter.
Und man sieht dann, den Patent geht plötzlich viel, viel besser.
Danke für eine Frage, Stille.
Ja, na klar, bitte schön.
Ja, ich habe mit vielen Patienten,
die eine hohe Calciumwerte haben, beschäftigt.
Und ich war ein Assistenzarzt als Gemeinschaft.
Und wir werden immer erst
Isotonik, Infusion und Diuretik benutzt.
Oder?
Es hilft nicht, es hilft nicht.
Das waren sich unsere Erfahrungen.
Und sie müssen relativ rasch handeln.
Und das musste wirksamste Medikament.
Sind wir nicht nur die, die wir haben.
Das musste wirksamste Medikament.
Sind bis vor der Sonate.
Unsere Patienten hatten nie so hohe Werte.
Sie hatten zum Beispiel, die hochste Werte war bei uns.
Sehen.
Und die Patienten hatten 11 oder 12 Milligramm, glaube ich.
Und bevor Operationen,
wir versenken diese Werte,
wie immer benutzt,
wie Infusion und Diuretik.
Das ist ja eine andere Situation.
Man spricht noch nicht direkt von Südkaltzämie,
sondern da ist das Kanzel nur ein bisschen erhöht.
Wir sehen oder nicht zu nünft, aber das ist jetzt nicht gewählt.
Aber was ich vorgestellt habe hier in Deutschland,
ist üblich, dass man in Millimol Politer angibt.
Und da ist der obere Grenzwert bei 2,6, bei uns jedenfalls im Labor.
Und dann kommen Leute mit Calcium von 3,4.
Ich hatte jetzt letztens auch jemanden gehabt mit 4,1.
Das ist ja fast das Doppelte.
Bei Ihnen wäre es zum Beispiel 20 oder 25.
Das können Sie mit der isotonischen Lösung plus Diuretika gar nicht senken.
Das geht gar nicht.
Und solange dieser Werte nicht rasch runtergeht,
wird die Symptomatik nicht besser.
Dankeschön.
Bitte schön.
Okay, gut.
Gibt es noch weitere Fragen?
Was wollen Sie dann machen?
Was welche Richtung wollen Sie dann machen?
Einer Kollegen hat geschrieben,
dass in der Türkei die Phosphonaterapie
ist nicht besser von der Krankenkasse,
ohne festgestellte Krebsdiablosis.
Das ist leider ein Problem der Türkei.
Ja.
Das ist doch ein meditänisches Problem.
Das ist leider ein Problem der Türkei.
Weil Phosphonate als Therapeutikum
ist sicherlich bei Knochenmetastasen,
bei Manikinität sicherlich Voraussetzung.
Aber in diesem Fall ist es eine Notfalltherapie
bei unklarer Hyperkreisämie.
Normalerweise würde ich auch Phosphonate
den nicht geben,
wenn bei jemandem der Zahnstatus,
der Kieferstatus nicht kontrolliert ist.
Weil Phosphonate die Gefahr von Kiefernekosen mit sich bringt.
Wenn jemand mit so einem Kalzierung kommt,
das ist lebensgefährlich.
Deshalb muss man dann sofort
mit Phosphonaten reingeben.
Und das ist hier in Deutschland auch zugelassen.
Wir lernen ja hier mehr für Deutschland
und nicht für die Türkei.
Das, was in der Türkei war,
müssen wir jetzt langsam mal ein bisschen
bei Seite tun vergessen,
sondern die Üblichkeiten,
die vorgehensweisen hier in Deutschland lernen.
Das ist ein zweiter oder drittrangiger Charakter.
Viel wichtiger ist,
dass man im ersten Moment gleich nicht Phosphonate hat.
Das ist das A und O.
Man kann sich fragen, ob man nicht vielleicht
so Tabletten geben kann.
Leute, die eine Osteoporose haben,
nehmen einmal die Woche so etwas wie Phosphor-Max
oder Allendronsäure, das reicht nicht.
Das ist zu schwach.
Man muss schon intravenöses inklusionelles Phosphonate
nehmen, weil nur dadurch,
dass freie Calcium aus dem Blut in die Knochen
reingeholt wird und dass diese Hypercalcemie
im Blut gesenkt ist.
Sonst kriegt man das nicht hin.
Eine Frage, wie viel Phosphonate
muss es ja geben?
Das sind von den Gruppen.
Es gibt einmal die Toilette-Ronate-Gruppe,
wie das ist, so mit 4 mg eine Dosis.
Oder wenn man nie einen Insuffizient ist,
gibt es die Pannidronate-Gruppe.
Die normale Dosis ist 90 mg.
Das Pannidronate muss man langsam laufen lassen,
so über 3 Stunden, während das tolle Dronate
in eine halben Stunde reingelausen wird.
Da schreibt jemand Calcitonin.
Das ist sicherlich auch möglich, aber hilft nicht so schnell.
Calcitonin-Therapie ist so zweit
oder Drillenientherapie, wird hier auch in den
Lehrdüchern mit ausgeführt.
Aber im ersten Moment ist es vorhanden.
Das Lieblingsmelanom kann in bestimmten Fällen machen.
Aber ich habe jetzt vom Melanom noch nie gehört,
dass es eine paranäoplastische
Hyperkalzimie macht, ohne Knochenmetastasen.
Knochenmetastasen können das so weitragen.
Unter anderem natürlich als allererstes Myolome,
weil das spielt ja im Knochen ab.
Oder Postatakazinome, die machen auch viele
Osteolysen, osteoclastische Metastasen.
Das kann das Calcium auch mal hochgehen.
Aber das ist keine paranäoplastische Situation,
sondern das ist einfach ein Zersetzung.
Sprich, das Knochen wird einfach zersetzt.
Und es wird einfach viel kalziumfrei in dem Falle.
Von paranäoplastisch verstehe ich,
dass der Tumor, dieses Tumor associated
oder related paratomon produziert.
Und dadurch wird dann einfach viel kalziumfrei.
Gut, normalkalziumnum natürlich auch.
Das macht auch sehr gerne Knochenmetastasen.
Das ist schon alles in Ordnung.
Gut.
Wenn keine weiteren Fragen sind, dann wäre es das von mir.
Danke schön. Vielen Dank für dieses Gespräch.
Diese Zeit, dass Sie mit uns herbringen.
Herbracht haben.
Gerne. Wenn ich es so gut habe, mache ich das natürlich.
Vielen Glück und schönen Abend noch.
Danke schön.
Schönen Abend Ihnen auch.